hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this lesson
what we're going to talk about is
binomial probability so what is binomial
probability and how do we work with it
well okay binomial probability basically
means that there's only two things that
can happen like either you win or you
lose or it's like you know you make the
shot or you miss the shot or it's like
success failure okay it's like one of
two options you know heads or tails that
kind of thing so if we take a look at
the formula here we've got n choose K P
to the K times 1 minus P to the N minus
K so what what all these variables
represent well okay n represents the
number of trials okay so the number of
times you flip a coin or you know a
number of basket shots that you take or
whatever it is that you're working with
okay and then P what P represents is the
probability of success as a decimal so
if it's a 20% chance of success that's
0.2 0 and so on and then 1 minus P is
the probability of failure so there's a
20% success rate that means there's an
80 percent failure rate because they
have to add up to 1 right 200 percent
and so K here represents you know the
number of successes so you're wondering
if the probability that you know you
make you know 9 out of 10 baskets or 5
out of 10 baskets that's the number of
successes and then and minus K that
would be the number of failures so we'll
look at some examples I'll show you what
I mean so let's take a look at this
first one if you make 70% of the
basketball shots you take what is the
probability that you make exactly 9 out
of 10 shots okay so let's look at this
one so basically you're taking ten shots
so that's going to be 10 shoes we want
to make 9 right so this is 10 choose 9
we know the probability of making the
basket is 70% which is 0.7 0.7 and we
want to make nine of those and then the
probability of missing okay are not
making the shot is 30% so that's point
three zero or 0.3
and one of those so if we simplify this
10 choose 9 is 10 factorial over 10
minus 9 1 factorial 9 factorial and then
we have 0.7 to the 9th and 0.3 to the
first so if you simplify that out 10
factorial divided by 9 factorial is just
going to be 10 if you simplify that out
that's going to give you the probability
okay so let's look at another example
what is the probability that if you flip
a coin 20 times you get heads exactly 7
times so we're not seeing 7 or more
we're just saying you know exactly 7 so
same idea here what we're going to do is
we're going to say 20 times so that's 20
trials so you can see n is 20 and we
want to get heads exactly seven times so
K is 7 we know that when you flip a coin
there's only two possibilities you know
it's either going to land on heads or
tails and so that's going to be a 1/2
probability we want to get heads 7 times
of course not getting heads would also
be 50% or 1/2 okay getting tails and
that would have to be 13 of them okay so
if you simplify this quantity you're
going to get the probability as a
decimal and then you can convert it to a
percentage if you want to talk about
percent chance but again just with the
22 7 this is 20 factorial over 20 minus
7 factorial 7 factorial and then you can
simplify the rest of this here okay so
this is how you work with binomial
probability just remember it's when you
only have two options success or failure
and you can use the formula here so I
hope you're enjoying these videos I hope
you're learning something and getting
something out of it go ahead and
subscribe to the channel take a look at
some of my past videos and I've got more
videos coming here for you so stay tuned
I'll talk to you in the next video